let's see the gocbar will do a god thing
where you act with all that stuff today
just like literally right yoga and juice
and antidepressants I just moved to West
Hollywood
that's my god that's your turn to be
great my Trinity as antidepressants
juice and yoga and [ __ ] you go where
you have you be repelling maybe there's
a god I don't know not really
not to worry I would steal from you dick
sir my god
maybe where you had uh uh yeah I say
thanks to something every day uh you
know ah but it's just you know I mean
our whole job we're so lucky is just to
take the steam out of people's lives
like just let the steam out a little bit
and let people be happy for a little bit
so it's like long as you're doing that
you do it for the right reasons and I'm
not like yeah I'm doing this to get all
the [ __ ] or to get uh like like auntie
and you just want so much [ __ ] all the
time
no are arch again slap in the face just
getting beat up with hot gash he wants
now he wants to get followed by ax
wounds would you work sweet tender bad
really awesome we word okay sweet tender
go back to Jim discussing your epiphany
with Cosby of working clean all that bad
dripping then I have no clue whatsoever
honestly who knows I will say this yeah
her brother died left three kids I swear
in my life
now some may say was a dream whatever
but when he died for like ten seconds he
popped and that's the official when
someone appears in your life you need
that sound effect that's for you I'm at
my sister's house on a bed you know I
just passed out it was tired fell asleep
exhausted
for ten seconds we didn't we didn't talk
but it was all like he said listen to
care my boys and I can tell just by his
face there was going to be some turmoil
said please check in on them once in a
while don't worry about mom she has you
and the rest of family is fine now I
went holy [ __ ] what what about you and
he went I
super any kind would be out super it's
God now you know what I don't know what
that was
dream whatever I wasn't asking for it
but when I saw that that just blew my
mind if people say dreams whatever but I
don't know where he come yeah it didn't
feel like a dream I felt oh god no hell
no buried every day was as I know what I
experienced and when it comes our God
all that I'm not religious but I do
believe if you open yourself to that
channel there's something there where
you will get answers the product God
itself spirituality whatever I think
it's yeah how's it done
Yeah right there get that guy out of
here before the red gunfire but you told
me that your wife is kind of churchy
that was tough on a personal level
because she got into Christian music
which is horn for the demos like
automotive sorry but there's only so
many songs you hear let the balloon is
rude yeah one of the fundamental tenets
of Christianity is suffering I think we
just